RACHEL: But let me introduce
Joe while he's setting up.
I actually know Joe Kutchera.
We are alumni from Fordham
Business School.
So it's really exciting to
bring him in here today.
It just happened that he's an
accomplished author, and also
has been working on bringing
assistance to the One Laptop
per Child, through the proceeds
of his new book,
which he'll talk about.
Joe Kutchera, who's based in LA,
is here today to basically
talk about how the Hispanic
culture can thrive in the
digital marketing era.
And he'll talk about what we can
do as Googlers, as well as
people who are interested
in that market.
And what are the five
steps to success.
Joe advises companies on how
to best develop culturally
customized content
for social media,
newsletters, and websites.
He has two books, including the
first book, which is out
today on Amazon, called "Latino
Link: Building Brands
Online with Hispanic
Communities." Joe's also a
contributing author to blogs,
newsletters, and places like
the Fox News Latino station.
All of that is where
you can find him.
He's also a member of the IAB
board in Mexico, and is a
member of the Hispanic
Committee that is
the IAB in the US.
So please welcome Joe
as he's setting up.
How are we doing?
Good?
JOE KUTCHERA: Perfect.
RACHEL: Thanks.
JOE KUTCHERA: Rachel,
thanks so much.
Most Americans know three
phrases in Spanish.
Any guesses what those are?
AUDIENCE: Hola.
AUDIENCE: Hast la vista.
JOE KUTCHERA: Well, una
cerveza por favor.
AUDIENCE: Corona.
JOE KUTCHERA: Corona.
After a few cervezas?
AUDIENCE: Tequila.
JOE KUTCHERA: Un
taco por favor.
And then after a few tacos and
cervezas, donde esta el bano.
My presentation today, as Rachel
indicated, is about my
new book, which is actually
coming out in Spanish.
But what I want to talk to you
today is about introducing a
new word in Spanish to marketers
worldwide, and
that's the word for
success, exito.
And it's actually a five step,
or five letter, acronym for
how to you develop successful
digital marketing campaigns.
I have to admit, before I walk
you through the process, that
actually my first experience
with Spanish language acronyms
was, unfortunately
total disaster.
I was actually working at Time
Warner, working at CNN Money,
and then moved to Mexico City
to work at Grupo Expansion,
one of the leading media
companies in Mexico.
They have been the largest
business magazine,
"Expansion." And together
with the team there,
we started CNN Expansion.
And in that first meeting on
that first day, they started
using the word SEP.
And I thought to myself,
what is a SEP?
I had studied Spanish
for years.
But totally lost the meaning
of the meeting.
But SEP is a seccion especial
de publicidad, or special
advertising section.
So unlike that experience, I'm
here to actually explain what
my five letter acronym means.
We know the four P's--
place, price, product,
and promotion.
And it's been used for decades
for marketing planning about
where we are going to
sell our product?
And what's the price?
How are we going
to promote it?
And the retail channel.
But today there are a
lot of new factors
that we all know about.
Technology, chief marketing
officers actually spend more
than chief technology officers
on technology and big data.
There's a need for innovation,
coming up with new ideas.
There's a need for community
and content.
And there's a need to really
listen to our community, and
use that research.
And really the benefits of a
model break down a complicated
process into simpler steps.
And it makes things easier
to remember,
and share, and replicate.
Let me walk you through the five
step process for exito,
the word for success
in Spanish.
E is escuche a su audiencia--
listen to your audience.
What are they saying about your
company, your brand, your
competitors?
X is experimente
como usuario--
put yourself in the
shoes of the user,
develop user profiles.
We all know the importance
of that.
The third step is I, integrate
your communication channels.
How does social media and
customer service, are they
saying the same thing?
T is transform your audience
into a community using
storytelling.
And O is optimize.
These are all things we know,
but put into a format that are
easy to remember, especially
relevant for the Latin
American markets which, as
Rodrigo talked about, are
expanding so quickly.
Let me share a few stories
from my book.
And we'll walk you through
each one, one
story for each step.
So E, escuche a su audiencia,
listen to your audience.
We all know the importance of
user generated content, "Time"
named all of you the person
of the year in 2006.
And because of things like
Google+ and YouTube, that's
fostered things like Occupy
Wall Street, and the
revolution in the Middle East.
And here we see some graffiti
actually in Tunisia thanking
Mark Zuckerberg for providing
them with a platform for
organizing their revolution.
While that has a huge
implication, obviously on
leadership of both governments
and businesses, I'm not here
today to talk about
Facebook or Egypt.
But rather, how can visual
social networks change
marketers out there?
I'd like to share with you the
story of a case study from my
forthcoming book.
It's the story of 3M--
actually 3M in Mexico.
3M makes the post it
note, the square
colored pieces of paper.
And when they did a listening
study about what people were
saying about their products,
they discover that people
weren't talking about the
practical elements of their
product, but rather how to draw
Marilyn Monroe's face in
the office, or draw Steve Jobs's
face on a window, or
even play pranks on a friend,
and cover their car with post
it notes, or maybe even put
Pac-Man in the window.
So the folks at 3M Mexico, after
doing that listening
study, said why don't we just
create a marketing campaign
around what customers
are already doing?
So they actually created this
virtual wall where you and I
can create a profile, and
actually draw different
designs using different
colors.
Here we see someone writing
out the word
for moda, or fashion.
And then actually print
out a shopping list.
Put in your zip code.
And then find out where you
can buy that, what's the
nearest retailer.
In conclusion, really, the
benefits to listening that 3M
showed here are how an
inspirational idea can come
from the audience directly,
how it increased brand
awareness, how what was once
a commodity product became
differentiated through the
marketing and communication,
how it increased sales and drove
traffic to the stores.
But I think what's most
interesting about this is how
this idea started in Latin
America, and is now being
replicated in South America,
in Asia, and how innovation
can start in the emerging
markets.
Also very interesting, how
a paper product from the
pre-computer world has become a
pixel in the new world, and
become more relevant in
the interactive world.
Step number two, X, experimente
como usuario a
traves de perfiles.
How can we put ourselves in the
shoes of the user, using
user profiles?
This chapter in our book is
inspired by this behavioral
economist you see here.
Dan Ariely, he teaches at
MIT and Duke University.
And he's the author of
"Predictably Irrational."
And you see on his face there's
a scar on the lower
right side of this chin.
And in his book he talks about,
when he was 18, he was
in a severe--
80% of his skin was burned.
He was in a gas explosion.
And that really changed the
direction of his life, and set
a course for him, for his
professional work.
And while in the hospital,
he discovered--
his body was covered
with bandages.
And every day, the nurses had
to change his bandages.
But they removed them
very quickly.
Because they didn't want to
experience the patient's pain.
From his perspective, patients',
it was much easier
psychologically if the nurses
removed the bandages slowly.
So really what it showed was how
can we get out of our own
head, and really think about
the user's perspective.
We draw a parallel in the book
of how companies, we all want
to hit our monthly and
quarterly numbers.
But at the end of the day, the
customers just want their
problems solved, which shows
why it's so important to
develop profiles.
So when we're developing our
marketing campaigns, and
social plans, or marketing media
plans, how we can think
about it, according to
different profiles.
The kids case study in the book
that we have here that
exemplifies the step
is Banamex.
Banamex is the division
of Citibank in Mexico.
And they really successfully
developed user profiles to
understand, what do low income
consumers in Mexico and Latin
America need for a
banking product?
Currently most people
in that audience do
not have a bank account.
So they went to the Mexican
government, and they reduced
the 20 pieces of information
that were required of people
down to eight.
And when they developed their
marketing program--
this is in Spanish here.
But they developed a of three
step marketing and word of
mouth model for promoting their
product, and baked it
right into the product
development.
Where, when someone signs up
using their phone, their phone
number becomes the
account number.
And they can invite the people
that they have on
their phone to join.
And when that person signs up,
each person that signs up gets
20 pesos deposited into their
Banamex transfer account.
Obviously the word of mouth
element was baked right into
how the product was developed.
In conclusion, for step X, or
the second step here, it's
important to understand the
perspective of customers, what
problem they need solved.
Document how they spend
their time.
And we can use day in the life
plans to develop our marketing
plans and understand what
motivates them.
For step three, I, integrate
your communication channels, I
want to share a story that
happened to me while I was
actually writing the book.
And this chapter, you could
say, was inspired by your
nemesis here at Google,
Bill Gates.
"Your most unhappy customers
are your greatest source of
learning."
And of course the best place to
find those happy customers
is on social media.
So much like this woman, I was
in the airport in Mexico City,
waiting for a flight
on Volaris, the
discount low cost airline.
I'd printed my boarding pass
in advance, went through
security, was looking
at the screen.
It said wait in area B.
So I waited in area B. 20
minutes before the flight
left, I went up to customer
service and said, what gate is
the flight leaving from?
It still says area B. She said
they announced it many times.
We don't control the screen.
You're going to have
to run to Gate B.
I, quick, ran to Gate B,
coffee in hand, coffee
spilling out of my cup.
And I got to the gate.
And they had just
closed the door.
And I said, can I get
on the plane?
I have my ticket here.
They said, no, I'm sorry.
You're going to have to
buy another ticket.
I said, what?
You're kidding me.
It was still about 10 minutes
before the flight
was supposed to leave.
A couple other guys showed up
with a similar situation.
And we walked back to the
customer service agent,
complaining.
She said, no, you're going to
have to buy another ticket.
I said, you're kidding.
We went down to the ticketing
gate to complain.
And explained it again
and again.
I said, this is ridiculous.
I'm going to go ahead and buy
another ticket instead of
wasting my time.
So of, course later that day, I
complained on Twitter, just
to see what would happen.
Would Volaris respond?
Using the quote from Bill Gates,
and using the airlines
username on Twitter.
And what I get back?
Exactly what I didn't
want to hear--
a message in Spanish, an
automated response, saying
download our app.
Buy your tickets on
our application.
Clearly they weren't
listening.
So the next day I sent
an email to them,
explaining my situation.
And got a call back saying
we're so sorry,
please give us a call.
Called them back, but then got
this email with my incorrect
phone number, saying, we
tried to call you.
Please give us a call.
Social media, email, and
phone, clearly saying
different things.
So as this Volaris story
shows, the benefits to
integrating social systems with
customer service, how can
we develop better customer
service, learn how to improve
as a company, have happier
customers, and improve word of
mouth marketing?
The fourth step of the process
is T, transform your audience
and communities.
This is step is all
about finding the
needle in the haystack.
What's the content that can
attract our customers?
How can we create content that
has a magnetic force?
And when we developed our
process, my co-authors and I,
we really thought
about, how do we
learn lessons as children.
And when we think about learning
life's lessons, we do
so through stories like Aesop's
Fables, The Bible,
movies, and stories like
"Winnie the Pooh."
Interestingly enough, business
really is no different.
When we look at the management
guru Peter Drucker, who was
the author over 40 books, he
was once asked by "Fortune"
magazine, Mr. Drucker,
what are your
favorite business books?
And he said, actually I don't
read business books.
I read Shakespeare.
Because it provides the
most contextual
lessons for being a leader.
And when we analyze Harvard
business school case studies,
they're really no different.
There is financial information
and bullet points.
But it's really about a story
where the executives are
surrounded by contextual
information from the story.
One great a company that's doing
a great job with that is
BabyCenter.
Any of you here parents?
A few parents here.
Perhaps some of you
know BabyCenter.
Moms and dads sign up, put in
their email, the due date, and
then receive weekly updates
about what to expect when
you're expecting, or during
the first few years of a
child's life.
But in addition to developing
that database and their
newsletter of content, they also
provided a platform for
moms to share their stories
of where they are in their
journey, not only in the US, but
all across Latin America.
Next I want to show you two
videos from Mexico.
The first is a viral video
that really exploded.
And then the second video is
a video that Pepsi's cookie
division, Gamesa, in Mexico,
how their ad agency saw the
possibility to transform that
viral video into their own
story, and tap into the empathy
that some of the
viewers felt for the characters
in the first story.
So let's take a look at those.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOE KUTCHERA: So the viral
video brings out
the empathy in us.
Let's see what Gamesa
did with that story.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOE KUTCHERA: How many
of you speak Spanish?
A few of you.
Then, for those of
you that did, you
understood the tag line.
Full of power, and how
these cookies can
actually empower you.
And what's great about this is
not only how they turned that
first story into their own
story, but that that story
actually continues today, how
the emperors and the Roman
guards come in and
save the day.
Although today they're actually
saving beautiful
women from being heckled by
construction workers in their
commercials.
In conclusion, magnetic
content can
attract your audience.
Stories can create ideas that
stick in people's mind,
engaging stories, and empower
people to communicate with
each other.
The last step in our process
is optimize.
We talk about A/B testing
and other things.
But I want to show you an
example of how one retailer
actually optimized the retail
experience, and brought social
data into the store.
Here you see the retailer C&A,
a clothing manufacturer,
actually put the number of likes
that each product had on
its clothing hangers to show how
popular each product was.
And here's an example of how
one supermarket chain used
Twitter, and developed
an algorithm.
So that when you actually use
the hashtag in Spanish,
#quieroreceta, #iwantarecipe,
and then put all the
ingredients that you have in
your refrigerator with a plus
sign in between, it would send
back to you a direct message
about the recipe to use
with those things.
We know optimizing helped
us react to
customers in real time.
And it optimizes products to
benefit customers' needs, and
improves conversions.
In conclusion, listening to your
audience, we heard the
story of 3M, and how the idea
came from the audience.
X, experimente como
usuario, the
importance of user profiles.
The story of Dan Ariely and
his experience in the
hospital, and Banamex.
I, integrating your
communication channels, the
story of Volares, and how their
customer service and
social were saying
different things.
Transforming your audience to
a community, we saw the
example of the Pepsi videos
there, and the guards.
And O is optimize.
The research phase, planning,
and launch and maintain.
As I wrap up here, I just wanted
to share with you the
story about the next five to
10 years ahead for the next
generation of internet.
How can we use a model like this
one to really innovate
new products?
David is originally from
Bolivia, moved to the US to
study computer programming at
the University of North
Carolina, and volunteered to
teach Hispanics about computer
and internet skills.
And during the course of that
time, through listening, he
really understood their
need for developing a
new product for them.
And developed Pase La Voz,
or Spread the Word.
It's now the largest database
for US Hispanics in the US for
mobile or an SMS database.
Where he sends in short form
English lessons, classified
advertising, and
traffic alerts.
Which is exactly why we're
supporting Rodrigo's
organization, one laptop
per child.
Because we really see that the
future the internet is going
to require innovating new
products for the billions of
consumers who only have a mobile
phone, who come from
low income households.
And so we ask you just to spread
the word about the new
book, as it launches
this summer.
By the way, joining us on the
phone today virtually was the
office from Mexico City.
And I just want to thank two of
my co-authors for the book,
Alonso Fernandez and Karla
Berman, who are joining us
virtually from Mexico City.
And again, the book's coming
out this June.
So with that, thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]